the villains that we're dealing with or
a combination of several entities and
they all have something to do with our
separate stories that have been played
out in each of each of our own
individual theories so this isn't going
on for a while it was an obvious H
individual series but in this series you
will find out that the things that
happen to all of us basically we're all
become because of one entity and that's
what's going to kind of tie things
together and then we'll see that we'll
understand that before you know it
eventually we'll fight together or not
we'll do things in a certain way it's
very difficult when you all have such
strong passionate viewpoints the kind of
you know reconcile and make sure that
everybody's on the same page it doesn't
work that way but if we will do the best
we can there's a couple good fights in
there a few good fights I think I think
the ones that people will really be
pleased with are the ones that I have
with certain people I'm not going to
name but I think I think they'll be
pleased of that one because it just get
a kick out of it comic book stuff
hey everybody that's Mike Coulter's
everything is connected speech all the
way from the capital cities of heaven
down to Matt Murdock getting doused with
chemicals and getting his powers if
you're wondering what's going on Mike
Colter was at the MTV Movie Awards so
that's what this interview was taken
from he did this funny bit what they
were doing the Beauty and the Beast
intro number he put on some Wolverine
claws letting you know about the Logan
Luke Cage crossover that you didn't know
that you wanted they got to make this
happen that would be so badass but the
really important thing that he's talking
about for defenders is in how all the
villains connect so most of the time
we're talking about the heroes coming
together what brings them together it's
this big villain that Sigourney Weaver's
playing called Alexandra the other side
of that though is that of course the
villains on all the different series are
as connected as the heroes are and
before I forget there is a new round of
the Guardians giveaway - all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video uh that's a new
winner at the end of this but the heroes
daredevil Jessica Jones Luke Cage iron
fist they all shares a very general
hero's calling in common with each other
like we're all people that are down and
out on our luck trying to make our
community better we should be finding
together not against each other in come
to find out that we're actually fighting
the same people even though it doesn't
seem that way that's a pretty easy sell
but what Mike Colter is saying is not
only does Alexandra have her hands in a
lot of pies with the villains from the
other series like Diamondback from Luke
Cage the kingpin from daredevil the
purple man from Jessica Jones in the
hand from iron fist she also shares some
responsibility in the fact that they
became heroes the way they got their
powers so that's really the cool thing
to me because they didn't necessarily
need to do that but it just binds the
heroes in a much deeper way and of
course it totally makes sense when you
think about it wouldn't it make sense
the ultimate villain for the defenders
had a hand in creating their own worst
enemy so going around to each of the
series what does that mean daredevil he
got chemicals spilled on him that's how
he got his powers that means that
Alexandra was behind that chemical truck
she probably didn't mean to give Matt
Murdock powers but he got them stick
chased him down and that's probably why
stick sawed him out because that
chemical truck had something to do with
Alexander's organization stick saw what
was happening in wanted to Train Matt to
tear him for this war that's coming
moving under Jessica Jones the IgH
corporation the pharmaceutical company
that gave killgrave his powers as well
as Jessica Jones and will Simpsons pills
they're saying sigourney weaver's
characters behind that as well that
company is trying to make combat
enhancers so that's why they're
experimenting with people that can
control other people's minds that's
where killgrave came from they developed
the straight-up combat pills that well
simpson was using so you have military
applications menu a blue cage in the
experiment that they were using to try
and regenerate human tissue
that gave him his powers that character
shows up at the end to come for
Diamondback implying that they're going
to give Diamondback the same treatment
that Luke Cage got will actually find
out more about that pretty soon because
the showrunner for Luke Cage season 2 is
actually writing that right now but we
don't know a lot about the company
that's funding Noah Bernstein's research
now it sounds like Alexandra is behind
that as well trying to make more super
soldiers and then you have Iron Fist
who's villain was largely the hand
organization a couple different factions
so the drugs that they were peddling
were intended to make people very
addicted very docile for big takeover
attempt so it sounds like Alexandra
using the forces of the hand using
modern research pharmaceutical companies
all these different things that pop up
behind the MacGuffins on the different
TV shows the totally accidental ways
that everybody got their powers in is
attempting to engineer a giant world
takeover now we really don't know what
the big plan is that's part of the
MacGuffin is like there's this big thing
that they're trying to get some gold are
trying to achieve that ends up not
really matter in the end it's all about
the heroes coming together what that
dynamic is like but we'll probably learn
more about what that actually is in the
next big defenders trailer because it's
not dropping until August I'm not
expecting it really soon they'll
probably have a really big fan Diego
Comic Con panel but just address the
other really big thing my culture said
in the interview is that it's going to
be a lot of fun when they come together
because they will fight amongst each
other big time if you miss it Brian
Michael Bendis is writing the new
defenders comic book it's made to look
exactly like the Netflix series it's the
same roster it's some of the same
villains like Diamondback is the big
comic book villain in the first arc he
said that because the personalities of
each of the members are so strong does a
team leader will shift depending on
the threat they're taking on so if
jessica jones learns about some big
problem and she's the one that brings
the problem to the group she's the one
that will be the leader for that mission
and so on and so forth for daredevil
Luke Cage iron fist but like that last
moment in the trailer where Jessica
Jones is sitting at the table just
sizing up iron fist where she's just
like get a load of this [ __ ] that
will be where they kind of leave the
group w bros by the end of this but what
my culture is saying is that they're
going to fight a lot and they're not
going to resolve that at all so sort of
imagine it is like a lesser version of
what happened during Civil War the
Avengers are always going to argue they
have really big personalities there's
almost no reason for them to hang out
on-screen together because some of them
are very literally gods in their own
right thor style
why would Thor ever need the help of the
Avengers unless it was something of just
catastrophic proportions so you sort of
shrink that down to street level like
defenders level problems and it's the
same deal Luke Cage is almost unbeatable
daredevil is really good at what he does
he's an awesome lawyer in addition to
having badass blind ninja skills
what threat would be so great that they
would all have to come together and put
their differences aside the last big
tease though when he talks about being
most excited for the fight scenes he had
with a certain other person like I can't
really say what it is but it's going to
be so awesome
he's talking about comic book fans
getting really excited because it will
be genuine Heroes for Hire moments to
letting the smackdown on a whole bunch
of people you can bet just because that
is something that people have been
screaming for for so long since they
started doing these characters that they
will definitely put some Heroes for Hire
moments in the next big trailer so if
you're still confused about what the
story is for defenders what's going on
with the villain what the plan is that's
all stuff that they stick in later
trailers so don't worry they'll spell it
all out before the series starts and
I'll be doing bonus videos too so leave
all your requests for defenders videos
in the comments below Jessica Jones
season 2 just started shooting daredevil
season 3 will start shooting later this
year they just wrapped on the Punisher
they'll probably announce a release date
for that in the next couple of months
but they have so much stuff happening
with defenders that that's mostly what
they're focusing on but it's going to be
awesome there's a whole bunch more comic
book stuff I'm trying to get to this
week I have new spider-man footage and I
have my guardians Easter eggs so
guardians will be the next video to post
in this new flash congratulations to
last week's giveaway winner rich
Tranter please private message me so I
can get your contact details there was a
new round of this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a Marvel video so click here for that
spider-man trailer and click here for
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys tonight